Oh Calgary Calgary I'm there April 21 22
23 come laugh with me in Calgary and
then I'm in Philadelphia for cinco de
mayo I dated a girl named Michelle
tamayo she has a sister named Marlene
tamayo you say Cinco de Mayo I say Cinco
de made oh hey guys it's a new podcast
what thank you two new podcast it's a
great podcast those are my dates calgary
this weekend the 21st through 23rd of
april philadelphia stinking mio brea
improv 13 14 15 of May DC improv 19
through 21 helium st. Louis 26 to 28
blocked ooh and June's a big month I'm
not going to tell you the exact date but
birthday punker starts airing in June on
your birthday schaumburg nine ten eleven
flappers Orlando funny bone columbus
syracuse from adding some new dates to
fill up the rest of the fall and that is
my schedule today's podcast probably a
baby even an advertisement this month we
have an advertisement this month
Squarespace hold on one second my wife
will be here two seconds you don't play
oh here's my lovely wife LeAnn Kreischer
Leanne's having a bit of a day and you
can vent if you'd like they don't mind
hearing it this is a mess everything in
this house is a mess exactly like that
it's just nodded wires and cords
everywhere and bad printer cartridges
and stuff and I'm having a bad day but
if you're trying to build a website
which if you were building a website
today you'd be getting your ass handed
to you correct I would be yeah but if I
were then I should probably choose to
use squarespace com because it's super
user friendly
really really user-friendly to build
your own website and this episode is
brought to you by Squarespace you can
start building your website today at
squarespace com and if you enter the
offer code Burt cast ber TCA st at
checkout you get ten percent off your
first purchase if square crisp if
Squarespace could only change a printer
cartridge at abusive hey how about this
guy's go to Squarespace and just build
some some real greatly and friendly
websites and then send them to us so
that Liam got a website for Georgia I'm
sweating my ass off and you're making me
hotter okay [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] right
now no you can't play the piano mom and
i are working that's what bought that
piano all right can I tell you my new my
new venture I wanted you know that Mike
I'll stop it George both you guys stop
when we add on to this house we won't
even ever to have to see them anymore we
can close the door and just throw some
food on the floor and wish him the best
oh I can't wait um Michael Strahan left
Live with Regis and Kelly Michael
Strahan is it never mind my whole goal
is to get on live I want to be the new
co-host on Live with Regis and Kelly yep
I want to I want to be the new co-host
he just hasn't been on there for years
oh yeah live with Michael and Kelly it's
gonna be live with Burton Kelly Kelly
and Burt probably she'll go first and
then we'll have to move to New York
would you be comfortable with that I
don't know I can do I you know what i
can do is what Michael does is i'll just
take private jets back off fridays so
you'd live there Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday come home friday
saturday sunday my stand-up would be
spectacular i would just hang out the
store or the seller every night and just
work stand up come home see you guys on
the weekend you do all like the heavy
lifting [ __ ] I already do all the heavy
lifting [ __ ] Jane there you go there you
have it ila shut up all right today's
guest is uh is a big I'd say in the
industry we use the term call get too
big get for me I'm a big fan of hers
I've been a big fan you know I was said
to store in the podcast and i don't i
don't know if it's
it sounds odd to think that me like the
quintessential bro comic or would I
think that's what people who don't do my
style comedy didn't call it but but I'm
inspired the most by a lot of female
comedies comedians are like my favorite
comedians and this person in Sarah and
Sarah Silverman and Janeane Garofalo
were big inspirations to me when I just
left college and I was trying to watch
comedy and so funny I don't have like my
you know obviously I left Kennison when
I was in sixth grade but there was a
real gap um in guys to watch that you
know like the I just didn't have that
guy and I saw her I saw a janeane
garofalo and I saw Sarah much sarah
sallon when I saw Sarah live but I was I
think these guys not to held her on this
podcast show that a second just really
inspired me to kind of do a different
style of stand-up and I i would venture
to say that i'm not technically a bro
comic that I'm a storyteller kind of
stream of consciousness and we write
their assembly me and her and I was
really excited to talk to her and I sat
down in her house which is absolutely
gorgeous leann gorgeous house you would
love it she's got a new album her name's
Margaret Cho I should say that right now
so you know who we're talking about
before download this you know who it is
she's got a new album called American
myth it's she's on her website it says
pay what you want go to our website it's
at Margaret Cho com Margaret is M arg ar
e TCH oh she's got a new video out
called the Anna Nicole song it's it's uh
it's out right now and you can see it I
watched it just five minutes ago it's
fantastic it's really great she's got a
great story about Anna Nicole we end up
talking about a lot of great stuff about
comedy sexual assault racism what
Georgia the podcast is not meant for you
baby girl maybe when you're in college
you listen to this and go goddamn my dad
hung out some cool chicks um so enjoy
the podcast it's a fantastic podcast
ladies and gentlemen Margaret Cho
it's long it's a long eyelash I hate I
always hate saying this to anyone of
Asian descent but it's in in Asian
culture they never put pluck long hairs
so I had a woman at a general meeting
one time saw the eyelash she was Asian
she was like oh my god don't mess with
that that's good luck yeah she ended up
buying the show so okay I was like oh
okay so I get them every time I'm about
to start making money oh yeah make sure
we are yep all right great i'm here with
margot 009 ever do that my podcast but
thank you so much for doing this thank
you it is good like any sort of long
hair you know what else it like because
it's like longevity yeah and an unbroken
line also in Korean culture anytime you
dream of a lot of feces it means that
you're going to make a huge amount of
money I'm an aggressive dreamer like a
lucid dream so like my dreams are insane
so as soon as you say that you planted
to see it i'll be dreaming up to eating
my own [ __ ] well it's very it has
something to do i think with koreans the
the word dome which is fresh it is is a
similar to tune which is for money yeah
so it's something but to do with the
language but also it's sort of a
folklorist thing but i also think it's
real because it happens like there
there's a weird yes can I tell you the
thing that's I'm overwhelmed with right
now is how small you are maybe teeny did
I don't know if it's from watching you
in like theaters or like seeing your all
of your all of your ads for anyone
anything you've ever done is so large
the notorious eh oh and and like that I
thought you'd be 10 feet tall I'm being
dead serious i was like i'm gonna get
there will be eye to eye yes and you are
like you are like petite you should eat
it it's gonna make a lot of money yeah a
little-little frame so uh um um we
talked to the very beginning about
straddling generations and i am one of
the things that impresses me the most
about your career is that I feel like
society opened up just enough or maybe
you forced your way into society just
enough that you
started in a business that was
horrifically sexist racist homophobic
and then in a weird way you kind of help
break down that barrier where it's a
conversation now and there are fan bases
that are said our fan bases that are
straight up gay like that and I'm
curious because I was working on some
sort of a bit of like if not saying to
an audience like acknowledge how good of
a person I have become cuz I grew up in
a shitty world in the south hmm like you
never get it like a pat in the back like
hey man just hey thanks for not saying
any hateful words and got five years but
like what's that like for you to see
that that change in audiences I don't
know i'm not sure if it was me or i feel
like you know it is sort of a collective
shift in the way that people change in
society changes and you know my
inspiration early on was Harvey Milk
because I was around a lot of young gay
people who are very into him politically
and then so it was like a shift of like
going growing up and doing comedy at a
lot of aids benefits and and doing a lot
of like political activism and then also
comedy that was sort of that my training
ground so maybe that has to do with the
world has shifted and I think the south
is very nice I lived in Atlanta for
seven years and know that not just
Atlanta Peachtree City you shitty here
so you know they're there is a kindness
and there's a sort of a general
acceptance of gay culture even though
there's allus Atlanta's got a very big
gay gay scene yes and I think that was
probably the San Francisco the south it
is Oh Little Five Points whatnot well I
always say this i look like a homophobe
I'm very open-minded oh no no I think
you look like a bear I got an offer to
do a bear I was show on travel channel
called one conquer and nice these this
bear publication reached out and they
were like hey we're big fat me my
partner big fans were a small
publication Francisco we'd love for you
to spread and you know you know how like
Barack was on the cover of out yeah and
you're like oh that's great you know we
in as an entertainer like it's good
press something I believe in okay you
know people will see me as another side
of me yeah and I was like okay I'm in
there like what
a lot of money and so you gotta fight
yourself up and as just it fell apart
but I ended up telling travel channel
about it and I go uh I was like yeah I
almost did this bear publication and I
was gonna like surprise you guys with in
their face went white and like for the
record you cannot do born hahaha let
alone gay porn if you definitely can't
do porn and I was like whatever you
thought that well they really loved a
very masculine sort of iconic sore
figure and then the other guy that they
really like from the genre of TV that
you guys do is micro they're obsessed
with him so funny they get very into
these hyper-masculine archetypal
characters but then the you guys both
have like this friendly side too so it's
like perfect for bears yeah but did need
to put a ball guy in micros mouth
because he is extremely put aside yeah
y'all I'm a like what he writes I like
that he writes you know but whatever
he's very libertarian busy I think he's
more is he more conservative or
libertarian conservative I think he sort
of Sir strikes me as then he's like it's
not a social conservative though he's
like a fiscal conservative but he's very
much there for like the working man it's
a clearly working man yeah I don't know
I feel like I feel like there's gonna
sound shitty i'm a big fan of micros
things amazing host but i feel like he
is he's put branding in front of
sometimes you know oh yeah you see guys
that are like i'm so blue collar and
you're like enough you're not anymore
you're yeah pretty wealthy talk about
what it's like first class you know yeah
butBut know what was the when you
started you were very I mean you were
television development friendly just
because I was so different and that was
a time of the era of people buying
stand-up comedy to do sitcoms so that's
like Roseanne Seinfeld a Tim Allen these
shows are very big and so when I that I
i I'd sort I've sorted be in comedian
like much earlier than that but my big
sort of move as a television performer
began with that sort of rift of people
really going to buy stand up into in
order to make sitcoms so that's where I
was very marketable because I was a
different you know is another arena for
people to go sort of a family sitcom
direct
Shin but were you were you biting your
tongue with your politics at that time
no no my comedy was still the same I
think that my comedy just became a
little bit better over the years but I
always sort of had the same message I
mean I was never supposed to be there
and so I think that was my you were
never supposed to be in that network
development well never supposed to be in
comedy you know like my my face and
appearances are different from anybody
else in comedy then yeah so that's
always like I feel like in comedy we're
always trying to answer one existential
question like what what seinfeld is a
good example seinfeld is do you see this
what look am I the only one seeing this
yeah and then mine is I know I don't
belong here so all the reasons that are
around that become comedy I find it
funny you know the people are drawn to
as a young comic were you and Janine you
had a joke that just that I went that's
the way I think but despite the fact
that we are I'm sincerely shocked that
we're in the same business sometimes
compared to what the art we put out
months i'll just say minds i believe
lowbrow more lowbrow but like but mine's
more fun at party you know you're just
definitely has a message and has thought
behind it you you referred to your mound
of pubis okay and i was like i was
saying my parents couch i was just i
think it was just out of college and I
was like who's [ __ ] than two words I've
been wanting to use to refer to mine I
love it yeah and so but but I feel like
I feel like you know the uphill battle
you had to have with I don't know and I
maybe I'm obsessed with this maybe I
maybe I see that your your your growth
as a comic I feel like sometimes a lot
of comics do the same thing they do
every special after every special I'll
be professional yeah and I feel like
yours you're the one example of someone
who's grown every time they do an hour
it's not the same type of thing even oh
that's good thank you and you have good
taste that's good janina's I learned a
lot from Janine Janine is is really oh
that's me I think that's
oh okay he's I'll be right back sure oh
sure oh I'm sorry no of course do you
mind if I talk while you walk okay so i
will say this house is absolutely badass
this the art is fantastic the there's
pictures of Margaret when she was a
child there's a picture of Robyn there's
like an old Southern god bless our home
picture which I'm sure she got in her
time Atlanta there's a samurai sword
this is like and it's like is is I think
maybe imagine I think it's got a huge
backyard with a hot tub her publicist
just show okay I want to hear about
myself I might as well let you know this
episode is brought to you by Squarespace
the simplest way for anyone to create a
beautiful landing page website or online
store the easy use tools and templates
Squarespace helps you capture every
detail in a way that drives you because
it's worth the effort it's worth to
sharing with the world go to square say
base body calm enter the off code bird
cast it check out and get ten percent
off your first purchase your come for it
I feel like I said get oppose us but why
one way if I can publicize a house like
this is where you end up 10 you this is
the house that you want to live in in LA
you know you know is this your publicist
hi how you doing good that's okay no
don't worry about it I'm sorry I'm sorry
we haven't talked about anything bad um
all good I'm not that kind of
interviewer by the way so what's but I
think and maybe I'm obsessed with it and
sometimes I think people put things on
comics that maybe weren't in our head
but I feel like there was this moment
where I went where I went uh Margaret
Cho went to like digital was it what was
it called digital fortress she was like
a porn site that lack in San Francisco
yeah kink.com King calm and it was like
they had that big fortress you'd ordered
and i was like i was visiting that site
or regular basis yeah and then i read
somewhere that you had gone there and i
was like oh [ __ ] Margaret Cho parties
like and then all of a sudden
you blossomed for me even more than ever
because um someone though we or maybe
you came someone who's extremely honest
who talked about sexual assault you
talked about stuff like that I was like
oh this is not this is not her just her
mom do you know what I mean oh yeah yeah
and so what was it and maybe I'm just
putting too much on this cuz I just in
an hour and I'm trying to figure out
what the next direction is but did you
feel did something happen no no I even
talk like I've been talking about
different subjects like coming into
talking about sexual assult I've been
talking about that for years but for
some reason you could never get an
audience to laugh at it because there's
a need for comedians for you to be
heroic you know that there there's the
eternal hero the comic always always has
to be here whether you're the underdog
hero or whatever you have to be heroic
and when you talk about rape and sexual
molestation suddenly it's too much that
you can't you can't be hero necessarily
in that situation and so upsets
audiences or it triggers something but
now I think there's so much conversation
around all that stuff I mean when you
know we're living in a time like every
other day there's some kind of issue
whether it's dennis hastert or Cosby or
sinister he was the former Speaker of
the House and he was molesting boys and
he had he had allocated funds illegally
to pay off these now grown men for many
many years and so this is this is a
terrible terrible outrage and this is
the Speaker of the House you know this
is very very sort of a big top I feel
like after Sandusky and all of that
stuff that happened in in in a sense the
the world shifted and said we need to
talk about this more because we need to
fix it or find a way to stop it and so I
had been putting it in my act over time
but it's a journal argument with my
family so they they're they're very
invested in silence and not talking
about these issues and so we've been in
a fight about this for three
years and so that's it so that goes
beyond my comedy but I've decided to
like actually like really push it and
work on it and now it's starting to make
it the world is shifted to make it sort
of okay to talk about when you feel
pushed back when you talk about stuff
like that what what's the stereotype
that you see the pushback from is it um
you can't talk about rape on Easter you
can't talk about rape on Easter wait
that's my favorite I was at a comedy
club and they were really mad that I was
it was like you know it's not going well
and then I you know when it doesn't
sometimes when it doesn't go well I
really liked to I'm gonna I know you
don't like me well I'm gonna make you
hate me cuz there's just no like I have
to have an extremely yeah no no oh I've
been there where I go I got into this
known okay I'm sorry keep going going no
God I know that feeling yeah but there's
woman stood up and scream you can't talk
about rape on Easter which is my
favorite was that busy sir yeah it was
just the 16 shut up that's like fresh
yeah ownza shut up so it's really funny
what that's so crazy so what were they
like what were they expecting well I
don't know exactly but I think sometimes
also there's a difference between like
when you do clubs and when you do like a
big show at a theater where I do both
and sometimes at clubs you get audiences
that don't know what they're coming to
see you know there's like oh let's go to
the comedy club because they you know
they just want to go out and so they're
not necessarily familiar with the artist
or you know whatever and so it just it
just becomes a thing where you sort of
needing to introduce yourself a little
bit every time you go on stage you sort
of need to introduce yourself a little
bit but then they were just in shock
about it and like very upset some people
don't feel like some people go to comedy
clubs you know realize that the best
jokes for us are the ones that I must be
falling for myself but the ones that
were you I want to talk about subjects
sometimes that I did they don't think
they'll laugh at and then they go well
[ __ ] I just found the humor in that yeah
like but I think also in that same thing
it's like whoa
what bothers me about that is i'm
assuming i'm assuming they would have
loved a well-crafted like rape joke from
a man right right no are there are there
any wellcraft the only yeah there's a
bunch o really like i like we're very
different we've did look I have the same
sensibility as you but I'm also on the
other side of the fence also Daniel Tosh
Daniel Tosh still one of the best rate
jokes I've ever heard yeah then like and
like I look I Hewitt I don't want to do
it said it would never do it justice
right because then people would take it
out of content yeah and it wasn't the
rape thing that he got in too but like
Sarah did a bunch Oh Sarah screams Sarah
is amazing you know and I and I would
venture to say that I as an audience
member when you brought a break I'd
almost be like I can't wait to her
viewpoint yeah so I don't find I don't
get I don't get offended at all I'm just
not that's not my that's not my
personality um but i would but i would
be blown away that someone would not
hear that at your mouth and go I can't
wait to hear this perspective as opposed
to tosh who I love to death or that
would get a standing ovation you know
what I mean yeah yeah it's weird though
like you get you go into these things
when you go into an easy sort of arena
where where people have very firmly held
beliefs like okay we have to have
silence and shame around rape and then
you can't talk about rape on Easter
makes me just go well Jesus is a rape
baby God didn't ask consent there was no
consent in that argument and he's just a
mistake yes very upset Marv's it and
then you go oh well why do you celebrate
Easter when the rape baby zombie clawed
his way out of the coffin and it
confronted everybody it's like them and
then people get like so angry you can't
like question he's firmly held beliefs
about religion about rape about silence
and about sort of dignity that was
supposed to give to what I consider a
fiction you know I I come from a very
religious background and I actually was
a Bible studies teacher so I really
I've gone through many years of knowing
why are we taught that's why our
children taught this it when really it's
such a fiction you know it's really
there I think there is the spirit of
good in people and there is maybe some
sort of idea of an overriding
spirituality or oneness that we have but
I don't think it's necessarily out of
the Bible yeah what do you would what I
mean you feel like I feel like your
house is a shrine to spirituality in a
weird way yeah what is what we're do you
sit I have a lot of different spiritual
beliefs there was a time where I was
really interested in Santeria because
it's a beautiful religion because it's
basically in Yoruba religion and African
religion brought over and disguised as
Christianity in order to fool the slave
owners you know so it's it's a way to
keep your traditional beliefs but use
Catholic iconography so that your slave
masters will assume that you've
converted and I think that's a really
beautiful thing and then my family is
very Buddhist and ancestor worshiping
but also very Christian too so they have
their own sort of form of whatever that
is that form of pretend conversion yeah
so this there's a lot of different
things that I I sort of i do you know
where they're from all of the different
traditions is your mom up and minded yes
in a way I mean she's definitely like I
see I see the ghost he's my family like
they're really Christian but in 1978 my
grandparents had to have their 50th
wedding anniversary in San Francisco and
we had like couldn't find a venue and
I'm a mom was watching TV and the
Jonestown tragedy it just happened you
know where 900 something people died in
Jonestown but that meant that the
people's temple in San Francisco was
vacant so she was like I have an idea so
then we rented out the people's temple
and it was a very it was a really bad
party but because my mom kept seeing
ghosts that were missed that we had like
come into this place where they they had
been very betrayed and then taken to
Keanu and and they'd all come back to
the site she said they were all there
they were really angry angry at her for
having a party serving
food that they couldn't eat and really
late late all this stuff yet but it was
a very intense thing because she was so
identified as a Christian but she still
saw like sort of ghostly things she
still believed in ancestor worship which
I do now to my own icons like I I go to
the Buddhist temple and I burn things
for Joan Rivers like I went to Hong Kong
and I bought her a little Yorkie dog
like a paper dog and some paper jewelry
and and some pastries and I burned them
in the altar to her and they burned up
really quickly so it made me think oh
she wanted it so it's nice who was she
she was she one of your heroes early in
comedy okay yeah really I mean was when
I saw her I realized like I saw her TV
when I was really young when I realized
oh and Carson Carson and she hosted SNL
remember when they used to have like
comics he's do sets on SNL sis you she
did one Andy Kaufman did 1 i'm steve
martin very famous seated many yeah um
so you would see comics there and just
doing comedy and so she was one of the
people that made me think I I have to do
this so but she was major and Bill Hicks
so major did you get to I mean I don't I
don't know how all you are assuming
you're older than me but I'm 45 I'm 43
okay I should have done a little more
research I just I feel like if I do
research than I asked questions on the
internet as opposed to the things that
I'm interested in I'm sorry but um
that's oh wait did you get to did you
get to see him work live all the time i
used to open for him [ __ ] phones I
used to open for Hicks and then he had a
special affection for me because I was
dating as my first boyfriend was one of
the big Houston guys and so all the
Houston comics really love t Shan
Shannon you can ride on SNL I just heard
um I just heard Janine talk about t Sean
oh yes yes yes and I knew T Sean did he
have a brother yeah Charlie died yeah
Charlie who passed away okay at warm I
did they were out of New York and they
were writing for someone when he passed
and they my I don't know whether who he
was right if you had written a feature
and that they were riding together yeah
yeah he's gone about
15 years i think when i was a young
comic in New York I met t Sean and his
band maybe his brother but I only know
that exciting I remember his brother
passed I don't know how I know that if I
didn't ya livin in that but the yeah the
Houston comics all look to Bill Hicks is
like their father so you know I teach on
and I were living together and bill
would call up you know then oh you know
like he's like hey he's your man around
very very it was so so giggly and funny
and he he was so great like he was so
magnanimous chilis comics you know they
loved him so much so he had a little
special thing for me cuz I was like one
of the little girls around there and so
I opened for him a bunch and I saw him
in all sorts of different capacities you
know people sometimes really were angry
at the subjects that he approached and
really defensive and I remember not too
long before he passed away there was um
he had Dennis set and it was a it was a
Republican fundraiser that he had been
accidentally booked at and he walked
like 200 people and it was this big big
story you know back then it was such a
horror for that to happen but he was
just a genius and such a kind man too I
read the book about him and I i
discovered him probably early in my
career but later then i discovered guys
on TV that I liked yeah like I don't
know I don't know why but the people I
was drawn to on TV were not the style of
comedy that was gonna be doing not that
I don't do that not to put down my own
stand-up but but who did you like Eugene
oh yes I met Jeanine I did not go over
all no no look no but but but you know
all fairness I was a young comic and
still trying to figure out what I was
doing on stage I talked about my dick a
lot but you know at l was someone i
discovered laughs like I discovered him
when I moved to New York to meet you
Martin and I was like I've usually Dave
Attell and I was like no he's like
that's your gonna love only went back in
holy to this day I mean I don't find too
much because I think it makes it a
tell'n comfortable
oh he blew me like he was the guy that
like i sat in the back in the cellar and
I was like I was like I mean I almost
want to say I figured out how to write
jokes listening to him yeah I changed my
style obviously so do that but like I
mean one of my big jokes that I had at
the time was you know what cops hate
when you touch their faces like it was
just Patrice I was a big fan of a treaty
I love it chase oh really yeah yeah I
would have seen you in Petry's were
bought that what about Ed's know I love
to him it would be horrible to you no no
he he's actually in Bonnie's documentary
and you know Bonnie McFarlane as a
documentary cuz i think it's called why
aren't women funny yeah for women are
fighting is great and Patrice is mocha
Joe is a funny [ __ ] and I was like oh I
love it was weird getting a stamp of
approval from him in a weird way cuz she
was so critically honest about people
yeah did he said you're honest he said
you were funny you mean you were funny
yeah it made me feel really good but I
was always a real big fan of his
stand-up comedy I liked it cuz it came
from a different place do you didn't
expect it yeah one of the things I love
about your stand-up is that I mean like
I was in I was in Montreal whenever you
were there two years ago year ago and
yet my last year yeah that's here and I
do I don't do stand up with a shirt on
I'm a dummy it was a show and someone
came up to me in the like just a record
you'll never beat Margaret Cho and I was
like why scale ago she's dinner set with
her shirt off the entire time I was like
shut the [ __ ] up oh yeah yeah I was like
oh I just respect that freedom no yeah
well I mean why not you know it's it's
so like we all have the body and it's
funny to just sort of play with that and
play with people's like uncomfortability
about that you know TIG does that too oh
yeah she doesn't have breasts yes so
that's just a little more impressive
show off this thing that people are just
really don't expect so that's really
beautiful I'm really hoping we'll do a
topless comedy tour me you and tagged
that's good so wait when was um at what
point after being and you don't have to
answer this and if you want this taken
out I will totally take it out but at
what point after dealing with sexual
assault do you then sounds silly but as
someone i have no experience with it
almost reclaim your sexuality in such a
strong way well you try to do you know
you figure it out it take
so while though like you go through lots
of phases and I think for me healing as
has taken a long time because I I just
said you know like when you're young
then you get into weird situations but
you don't claim yourself back from abuse
you continue to get abused and then you
know what I grew up in this era where we
didn't have words for date rape we
didn't know what that was and so we
didn't codify it so we didn't know it
was happening when it was happening and
so I experienced a lot a lot of that you
know I think there was this expectation
in the 80s like if 80s Early 90s
whatever that if you went out with
somebody you had to do it like there was
this thing where you had to sort of
complete the action or the Ark of the
date and I sort of did that for a long
time big feeling really bad about the
consequences and then then you realize
okay I've got to reclaim this now and
and so I went through all this news of
different kinds of therapy and different
kinds of learning more about sexuality
in that I think that helped yeah was it
was when did you realize you were
bisexual I actually thought it was gay
initially and then I started to realize
also that it was more than that like I
was very much thinking okay now I
figured it out I'm a LESBIAN that's why
it's I feel different but then it it's
sort of like oh but i still like guys so
i don't know where then it's because
very expansive and i didn't have any
sort of people to look to about
bisexuality there was no sort of
evidence of any bisexual comics or like
that i could sort of go oh I could like
sort of for my life after that I didn't
really know yeah bisexuality is such an
interesting things I think everyone will
believe oh that's totally women are
bisexual but no man believes that men
are bisexual whatsoever but they are
they are I'm sure they are I just I I
feel like I feel like you're I've always
felt like you're either born one thing
or the other I think there's variances
of that I know that I know that but I
never really maybe that's just part of
cultures that no one had ever has felt
comfortable enough to sit on any my
friends to be like haber just so you
know I definitely kiss dude
maybe that's part of it yeah but there's
at the secrecy and this need to sort of
be have allegiance to one one arena like
you have to be this is it's sort of the
completion of your identity you don't
want to have to keep working on it which
bisexuality I think maybe sort of refers
to this idea that there's so much more
that we need to know but now as I get
older I'm going to another direction and
realize it i might be asexual you and my
wife yeah like you get to a thing we're
like oh i thought it was both maybe it's
nothing so that's an acceptable identity
and a newer one like that's part of like
we're thinking about LGBT and then
expanding it q and A's is some or
intersect you know q a I you know these
these different aspects to what we
originally thought and now there's more
so maybe where do you really don't even
know what QA is questioning a sexual
intersects what's intersects intersects
is when you are I think it's when you're
born with both or it's a feeling gender
fluid so you define within your own
spectrum so it's a I think that's the
way but it's it's it's also a way of
being born to where you feel in the
middle or you feel both or you know it's
if people are defined at their own ways
okay do you do you do you get excited
when you hear about new terms or new
steps out into the frontier of
acceptance yeah because it's it's really
young people deciding for themselves
like okay well this doesn't fit me I'm
going to create another identity and I
think that's really positive it means
we're growing as a society for allowing
people to define themselves but where we
grow we also shrink to like there's the
HP to stuff in North Carolina and you
know what I just I don't know anything
about that but I just saw that someone
decided not to do a show there because
of whatever's going on yeah huge
transgenders not being able to use that
whatever restroom they'd like me yet
they identify with you know that now
there's this idea that somehow
transgendered people are a danger
society but really that's not there not
I mean that's it's just a made-up thing
that is driving a homophobia driving
hatred and and unfortunately the victims
are the transgender community which is
so terrible and they're not they're not
a you know group that society needs to
protect themselves from they need to be
protected by society's so this is a ver
this is a real outrage happening that's
why all these people are cancelling
their shows in North Carolina and also
Mississippi and it's very it's a big big
big problem well now what do you know
adversely how do you feel like I'm sure
you must be aware that there are people
like Jerry Seinfeld who's your open for
it won't you open for Jerry um in in
they go this political correctness is
too much he's but he you know he's he
and I are tight and he is the best best
best guy and I think it's just he is
right to that there is a kind of sense
of like why are we afraid of these words
why are we and it's like you can't get
away with anything now because
everything is policed everybody has a
phone and every day there's another
outrage and another Twitter fight or
whatever and it's just a ridiculous kind
of we're policing ourselves and I think
social media almost takes the presence
of the Catholic Church in the 1500s you
know there's like there's still burning
witches there's still this overriding
moral arbiter that that we have to sort
of behave a certain way or else will be
punished and it's a very public shaming
kind of society now and I think that's
what's what he's referring to and that
it sort of gets Brooklyn rid of
political correctness but it's actually
much broader of an issue it's it's more
that you can't really say anything
without being questioned about your
feelings in your identity that's why I
think comedy is harder but then it's
also not if you are these different
things that represent political
correctness which is you know I'm a
woman of color and I'm queer and so
political progressive there's all these
things that make me sort of the quote
expert
or safe yes that sounds safe yes it
looked like I'm always nervous I got to
a place where I just said while I'm not
gonna talk about anything anything
brand-new that's coming up like
cisgendered I heard about it was like I
was like I was like you know and I'm I
almost this is and I feel like this is
the worst part about society these days
I must just ignore it and go I don't
even know what it is don't want that in
my brain right god forbid i'm doing
radio and I'm drunk and I'm flying
around and I throw a joke out but i
don't mean or just shut it down which is
even worse i think then asking right
it's self censorship which you don't
want an art but cisgender you can talk
about cisgender note that is really well
your sis gender oh yeah cisgender means
you're born into your gender that you
feel deeply held to that you feel feel
identified as so six cisgender is being
from the point of privilege so you can
talk about cisgender it's like being
white you get a bug leaving with you
can't talk about being white oh no you
can't die it's pretty nice but that's
funny it sucks but is it yeah but funny
though yeah no I mean I've definitely
made jokes about being white lightly but
you couldn't really take it a point of
view I made it I was making a joke about
catcalling mm-hmm this weekend and uh
and you know you take big swings
sometimes to see where the audience
lands yeah but premise is that America
hates its poor people that's whose
that's what I call yeah that's for
people with low self-esteem mm-hmm we're
doing he'll marry [ __ ] passes mm-hmm
that's and their cat call and it's
working clearly really it works cuz
there are other poor women who are with
low self-esteem who are accepting these
cat calls mm-hmm or they wouldn't be cat
calling right but as I start saying this
I realize look I feel like I'm being I'm
punching down I'm not I'm not making fun
of poor people but I'm letting everyone
in the audience know that they hate bore
people and then I'm like wait what the
[ __ ] do and then I say and this is the
sad part of where I think our of where
our comedy ends up having to where you
get to go through the door and I have to
stop is I don't have a dog in the fight
and then I lose it why do I care I
literally go Bert is it worth it is it
worth it to be
ostracized as in as as someone who is
then a predator because I agree with
whatever or whatever I say can be taken
out of context so I end up stopping at
the door right that's unfortunate
because you should be able to have the
freedom to explore these things as an
artist you have good intentions so those
intentions shouldn't be discounted but
yeah there is a kind of a social
paranoia that we will say something that
will be taken out of context and then
all over the internet and then you have
to sort of defend yourself or apologize
or whatever that is and to me that is
it's detrimental to art even though it
serves a function in that sort of says
we have to protect this element of
society or whatever but you're censoring
art so that that's where it's it i think
it becomes difficult its self-censorship
to an extent we know once entering me I
could say whatever I want right but it's
self censorship but it's so deep in you
now like it's a fear that's not allowing
you to grow as an artist which is in all
of us we all have that fear now and that
that I wish that we could somehow lift
that or that or as a comic you could put
in tied some of your money to charities
and go now let me talk about whatever I
want because you realize I'm a good
person right cuz that's I think that's
where people get lost is they think like
that that woman who said you can't talk
about rape on Easter sure I don't think
she understands I don't think she I
don't think she should be allowed to go
to comedy clubs like I really honestly
yeah they should take someone like that
and literally pull her to the side and
stamper yeah like you're not allowed in
comedy clubs normal purpose right what
was the what how do you write I hate I
hate to change subjects like that but
now I'm like like how do you write do
you find stuff that make you keep you up
at night or do you sit down and with a
pen and paper and you're like oh I don't
sit down and write everything out
there's no none of that I mean I do what
I do is I sometimes I have like a
subject than I need to talk about then I
have what I need to get out and then I
just go on stage with it and I know that
the adrenaline is going to force me into
a punchline like are you the same
[ __ ] thing is that great i love it
it's that's the best way to write that's
how bill bill hicks did it oh you just
made my [ __ ] day the adrenaline will
force me if I go up with the premise did
and and even if it's an angry premise
the adrenaline forced me to find
something funny in it yeah you have to
because you you are at a loss you need
that one thing and then that that will
push you into the right direction it
will open up another part of your brain
to do that so it's auto to autocomplete
but do you sit and go like listen to NPR
watching news then something kind of
fires you up and you're laying in bed
you chewing it over and over in your
head yeah sometimes but then I always
forget it with sleep so I do sometimes
write things down but in general it's
about figuring out what it is on stage I
like to do that set then things come out
that I don't even expect yeah so that's
and then I perform so often how much on
the road these days um every week I mean
so you know every week for me is like
wednesday through sunday and then
sometimes its clubs sometimes it's one
night or sometimes it's theaters
whatever it is but it's it's it's every
I try to do it once so my work week is
like yeah Wednesday Sunday and then the
rest of the time is off but you know you
just did you get I can't like take long
time off because I get forget how to do
it and forget what i did i find that
happening to me more and more i used to
be able take a month off and come back
and be right there yeah now i take a
week off and I'm like what was I talking
about last two weeks ago yeah it's
confusing and then you have to do your
TV show too so it's like you have a
different mindset you know towards each
and then like so I think it's easier to
come back into doing TV because you have
a lot of people helping but then with
stand-up it's like I'm the only one
Rogan and I Rogan by the way said hi I
love you he loves you he literally said
tell her I mean to call her I want to
hang out yeah I do i do love him so much
loves you i called my chickens relaying
double eggs and I'd know if they're a
safe to eat so I called him and he's
like yeah you can eat them oh yeah just
horrible your cholesterol you have
chicken I have three chickens you cute
yeah yeah um oh [ __ ] what was an oh do
you travel with like a like a team I
have an opener and Selena Luna she is
great she's really fun
she's a little person and she does a lot
of comedy about that and we also do
other projects together so it's nice to
work with her and then my boyfriend who
plays guitar with me so he's like a dude
on that yes nice Andy so he's working
fair he's um from San Francisco no not
grown-up so uh no no no but we grew up
parallel to each other but he's sort of
more the rock and roll scene and then I
was in comedy so we never actually met
there but we met through Linda Perry
actually who's the amazing singer of
four Non Blondes and oh yeah sweet
singer singer songwriter does a lot of
music like for pink and Christina
Aguilera and all these different people
but she's a good friend of ours have you
heard of what's her name i just
discovered her australian Barnett oh yes
she's wonderful quarterly Courtney
Barnett yes wonderful listener on the
whole flight in I know that I heard you
on a strombone aim I love Strongbow yeah
and I was like you named a few bands i
listened to and i was like oh [ __ ] work
i love what youve been done about to
music to yes yes as well you have a
beautiful singing voice oh thank you
thank you it's interesting you never
combine the two huh I do now it shows I
i will do a couple of songs at the end
it's a little weird though you know you
think oh it's got to have a comedic
element but i don't really do like
parody songs or comedy songs necessarily
so it's a different thing but it's a
good it's a good way to I think close
the show and nice for the audience but
to set up a separate thing I was think
oh should I have a separate identity for
that like like Donald Glover he's
childish gambino's I was thinking him
the last night I don't know he does the
both yeah thnkx oh but he has the
different identities but i don't i don't
know i can't think that much yeah where
do you see where do you see this next
hour we're taking you are you doing an
expat another hour yeah i'm assuming you
got one yeah yeah yeah that we won I
have to I have to finish out the tour
for this last one so I have to do sweet
hey we all worked out backwards so you
do your hour then you tore that our yeah
basically really I mean they sometimes
it goes the other way yeah yeah that's
the way I've been working it as I do the
hour that I release it not done with ya
so but this
when is sort of its I don't know it's
always just kind of weird so I did a
special last year and then I've been
touring it so it's just the sort of
backwards but then it ends up always
changing because you could never do the
same thing twice so like it's always
shifting so I did this all over America
and then I have to do some more dates
here but then I have to go to to finish
out I have to go back to Asia and then
Australia so I did Europe in England and
Asia and then now I have to go back and
finish everything else you tore Asia
yeah yeah that's a trip we're doin Asia
Hong Kong Singapore soul and so
hopefully I'll go this time to Manila
back to Seoul I did SNL in Seoul they
have a Korean SNL really which is just
the same it's like the exact same but
they do like Korean sketches and I did
you stand up but it was so scary because
I did stand a little stand up in Korean
which was really hard really yeah I'm so
scared wait what like that's that's
insane i can't imagine translating my
god and they i worked with them a long
time and translating and also kind of
like checking references and stuff they
didn't understand some things and it was
really hard but they really wanted it to
work and i wanted it to work so it was
but it was tough it's like so scary to
do that yeah well it's gonna be scary to
like how about how far do you go how
like do you find yourself self editing
when you're performing in seoul because
I by the way I don't know what I'm
saying so if it comes on offensive
please stop me but like I know that that
with homosexuality Asian cultures aren't
usually don't know and in Seoul it's
very homophobic and it's very like if
they have like they have a gay pride and
it's only one block well it's very small
and people are not allowed to take
photographs because they don't want to
be recognized because the people can't
be out at work or to their families it's
really a terrible environment you know
and it's much better in like Hong Kong
which has a very very big like gay
population but also that it's still
against the law there too so there's
like these laws like this weird laws
there's a car cane laws like in Texas
there's a weird arcane law that Ted Cruz
wants to implement that you can't have a
dildo you can't have a vibrator in text
this like you can't have anything that
stimulates the genitals it's such a
weird but now Ted Cruz is using that
like he wants to bring that low back
into like really enforce it you can't
what now I could give you my social
conscience for one day just like on a
vacation day for you it's like I
literally I get so everyone I just go I
don't give a [ __ ] I can't give a [ __ ]
about this we got the whatever that is
going on with the election I'm like I'm
not even a [ __ ] vote I just don't
care but uh that's insane there's a sex
toy that they have for men that I've
wanted for so long and I saw it one time
and I can't find it now what is it I've
gone to every sex store every time
looking for the same one it looks like a
stingray is hugging your dick like it's
and it vibrates oh oh so it's kind it
may be like a okay it's like a it was
like a fleshlight or like it it
literally looks like a stingray like a
baby stingray is hugging your dick like
one with its top of the wings on the top
and so are you okay and I guess I don't
all i know is that i saw at one time and
I was like never seen anything like it
I'm normally into it trying it that's
great like yeah but I can't find it
anywhere and it's it's i'll do some
research because i used to be on the
board of Good Vibrations celebrations
good vibrations is the largest online
sex toy retailer for women and so I
served on the board there for many years
and I have some background in BDSM I
worked at it a lesbian BDSM collective
in the 80s and the 90s and that's why
I'm close to a lot of the people at
kink.com so sort of my history really so
I know a lot about that world I know a
lot of a bet you know about sex work and
a lot about sex toys in particular so
that's something that I I can't think
it's like a cannoli almost but that's it
it's better than a stingray hugging your
dick and people II give I believe I'm
the I'm both cream yeah wait sweet you
were into that I did I did a segment for
BDSM for one of my TV shows with a woman
named mrs. isabella down and down I'm
having dinner with her in a couple of
weeks you are not yeah she's coming
we're doing I'm doing the irvine improv
and she's coming with a guy that I
really like jason Ellis who's a one
are you [ __ ] me no no are you okay
so like probably 11 no probably i don't
know if i was probably 28 maybe like 15
years ago I did a straight up like this
is back when when television was a
little bit in the Wild West like with
reality television and they would had a
show called hurt Burt right took
dangerous jobs one day I was a
dominatrix camp oh and i SAT with her
totally nude I mean the thing that when
I knew it was in television is when they
get me naked I'm blindfolded I'm
strapped into the stir up some tied up I
they take the blindfold off she's in a
full leather outfit with a zipper no
crotch her assistant it was gorgeous I
mean just gorgeous they're both in
rubber gloves and I hear y'all we got a
blood [ __ ] and I was like uh and there's
a whole film crew shot the whole thing
they told you 15 hours Wow no I did and
she gave me a video and said um you know
cuz I told her something like stuff I
liked and she said check this out and it
was like [ __ ] I had never thought of
this before the internet was away right
right and it literally peaked me and I
was like holy God like it opened up my
eyes to a bunch of [ __ ] no my wife and I
aren't like that and I don't really
explore that in my own personal life but
I find that BDSM culture fascinating
it's beautiful it's very important I
think it's very healing it's like one of
the few sort of very and things were
spirituality and sexuality combine and
connect and you get to a very deep place
and she's a master I mean she's really
brilliant I think she really probably
deserves something like a nobel peace
prize or something that's this Avenue
was she is so good like a MacArthur
grant something ya like like that
because she really is a genius and I'm
always very impressed by what she comes
up with and what she can do and she's
just a beautiful and gorgeous she's
really smart for myself yes I had her on
my podcast yes my wife and her connected
pretty quickly yeah she's cool yeah
she's really cool and Jason's I love
Jason I love him yeah well I would
imagine you guys would click immediately
yeah we have a good time yeah we have a
good time so he had a session with her
and so I wanted to bring them back
together
have dinner and hang out with his
girlfriend and her partner and so we're
all going to go do that in a couple
weeks how do you mess around with that
at all anymore no no that's it certainly
a part of my life that I don't really
revisit I think just also because I know
never I don't know like I never sort of
feel the urge to like it's something
that is part of my younger years but
it's not something that's sort of in my
self and in my sexuality anymore sort of
fades it's a think that's I've sort of a
I don't know something that's just very
sort of elemental but also true to me
but also i've sort of outgrown it in a
way maybe i'll return to it when i get
older what does you don't have to answer
this but like what turns you on like
what um i think what i like about BDSM
is that there is somebody in charge and
somebody that can be like totally
released so I'm sort of a switch in that
way so I'm both yeah and then I like to
see what is somebody's trigger you know
whatever that is with it what what what
is it that sort of gets to them in a
very intense way and so that's very
personal and very deep to go into and I
like the aesthetics of bondage I don't
like how it feels it's too itchy I
couldn't do it I couldn't do it you
didn't like being tied up no I look
nowadays I get claustrophobic yeah I
haven't been tied up in a very long time
but but I look at some of the videos now
and I'm like I couldn't do that and to
an extent I have panic attacks watching
and I'm like me ma'am I me nuts it's
claustrophobic yeah I don't like blind
folds because just they're not made for
Asian people because my eyeball sits on
top of my skull as opposed to recessed
in my skull so blindfold presses on my
eyeball this is the thing of Asian
people can never find sunglasses or
glasses or blind folds it's weird you
have to have like this it's just that my
bone structure doesn't allow it so crazy
I never knew that yeah yeah it's very
hard it's very weird really that's
insane yeah I i found out that i find
that the weirdest things these days like
down blousing was sexy what's down blows
Oh down blessing it's like I just I just
feel like I broke my governor from being
on the road so long
and then down blousing is it's the
weirdest videos it's not even like it's
just like a I guess a porn Dora hired
actress just cleaning the house and like
a loose fitting shirt oh that's so sweet
yeah its kind in a weird way it's the my
wife pointed out that whatever I was
watching was odds it wasn't stuff that i
actually did in my own life she's like
it's so odd it's a disconnect it's like
right you're fantasizing about something
that you'd never do right but when you
do it you're very submissive and
whatever anything I do I'm submissive
through and through but um and then I an
issues and then I was like looking for
something real I found quicksand porn
and I was like that's odd and then I the
land of the law well you know so funny
is quicksand porn connects with whatever
childhood sexuality you had playing
superheroes running away and getting
caught in quicksand and tied up and that
was the first sexuality that was
introduced to me through television
right and so that was like okay then
down blessing I was like oh that's so
sexy it's sexy and it's that's actually
very innocent too you know it's it's
almost like the awakening of sexual
feelings of seeing that you know like
your teacher or any sort of authority
figure any adult around you that's kind
of a the initial sort of first
introduction to the differences in
bodies and I like that weird one is a
sec I think it's called I forgot what
its aah and something it's a weird thing
where you go on YouTube and people too
and they're very good at like whispering
like it's a woman holy [ __ ] it's really
weird that's that you there are there
are fetishes like if you're heard of
unboxing it's like a massive fetish it's
it's not even if I don't even know what
it is it's videos where people just take
things out of a box then they have like
millions of downloads people just go on
taking this out of a box it's very
meditative yeah it's like very like I'm
stripping down I'm getting down to the
bottom of what's ever in my amazon prime
yeah no I don't understand the draw of
it but I've seen them I mean like I can
see that I
understand I always got weirded out by
when somebody isn't encased in plastic
like it's like a weird carbonite like
Han Solo finish yeah but when they you
know they put you sort of in a plastic
thing and then they come take out the
air yeah I've seen that well I've seen
it with you and it just oh yeah shrink
shrink wraps you in street grab see yeah
I saw one of those the other day and I
was like all that's in a weird way was
kind of like I was like I can see like
if I had the money and the time and I'd
have a job and it was just me and my
wife wind up kids I could totally get
weird yeah I think even now I'm just
hustling to get any sort of romance like
blue jet romance that's the other thing
is like when you're married you want to
I don't know why we're talking about
this all right look real quick I know
we've got to get you I would got to get
you out of here but uh I want to talk to
you about the business the change in the
business we were talking about that's
the very beginning of this and how
accessible I think stuff like podcasting
and shooting your own films making your
own TV shows making movies I think
movies still this uphill battle but
making your own TV shows making your own
webisodes and almost how you have to
wear like many different hats in this
business where are you going um well I
am in development to do a show at amazon
actually which is a for them it's a
drama comedy it's about an Asian
American family rising up in the medical
marijuana industry yeah so this is a big
show for them and big for me so we're
doing the pilot now and so that's next
but I'm still doing the road and doing a
lot of stuff and making music videos and
my albums coming out on April 29th
called American myth and the single is
out now it's called Anna Nicole it's
about Anna Nicole Smith and somebody was
very caught up in a lot of difficult
dark things yeah and it's a my candle in
the wind to her so goodbye Norma Jean
there goodbye English Rose it's that to
her where did you meet Anna Nicole Smith
at her house in I think 2002
or something like that and she we made
out what's really weird it was really
funny she's so beautiful experience she
was so lovely and and such a such an
eternal child you know she was probably
in her 30s then but she was so young
inside and and so she was a trip you
know and and what happened to it was
really difficult but I'm very proud to
have this memory and now the song which
is great I made it with hundreds of Anna
Nicole Smith impersonators that this
like Hollywood castle so it's like the
Playboy Mansion and so just going
through and they're all like dancing and
doing drugs and then I was like in the
pool and it's very it's very beautiful i
think the heartbreaking the
heart-wrenching part is that her son
passed away just right before she's just
a couple of days before i move yeah and
it was in the hospital in her hospital
room and then it when she yeah when when
he was when she realized he was dead it
took them four hours to pry her off his
body like she was so much torture the
baby yeah so there's a postpartum and
then this tragedy they both had the
similar kind of drug issues and they
also both grew up together you know he
was born she was very very young when
she had him so it's very I think I think
that was really too much it was very
hard know when are you guys gonna use
real marijuana and and a massage I don't
think so I don't think we can't i mean i
don't think i could get high and act
that would be really weird I've never
done that I think that you could
probably get high and do stand-up comedy
that's hard to though it's it gets
confusing its way out for me I've tried
it and it you're you think in I thought
in very large paragraph forms mmm if I'd
have a great idea maybe like hold on if
i can get this out to you guys you're
gonna love it I can't promise you I can
get it out yeah like I have the concept
really written down in my head yeah do
you need you think you need all of your
cupcakes or capabilities everything sort
of open but you're getting stoned in
doing that is hard but sometimes comics
like they have to get stoned before like
they just don't feel regularly
comedy and we'd have a very long history
that's a very like it's like a jazz
musician thing you know we sort of have
the same connection there it's some
people have a hard time connecting to
their sometimes I know you mean I know
some guys have a hard time connecting to
the freedom to like to letting you know
when you get high words will pop in or
things will see ya you're not in control
a little bit it's just it's almost like
you're like like flying through the air
ooh but I find I do stand up every time
I do it better sober like yeah that's
over yeah that's such a good stand up
yeah one cocktail and you can i but i
believe you can tell oh yeah me too yeah
i can tell difference but i like i like
to drink a little bit before but you
can't have to mature so you just like oh
you cuz it also intensifies in your
bloodstream when you're up there like
the adrenaline or something like makes
the effect of the alcohol even stronger
yeah so it's always very like it's
disorienting know where are you with
sobriety looks i know that you had you
partied pretty hard and then pulled back
yeah I am I was sober for ten years and
then I now I I like to smoke pot and
drink a bit you know it's something that
I I know like it's got its it's got to
be like age and maturity my approach to
it is different but it's it's something
that's sort of in my life and it doesn't
affect me like it did before yeah yeah I
mean I look at the way you create and
produce and it's just such a like it's
such a type of focus like you you don't
you're not you're not unfocused no and
so i imagine i imagine i don't know
whatever the booze and partying did for
you put you in a place to be focused to
know I can't imagine that shaking no but
then also showbiz is kind of a drug too
yeah you know show business is intensely
gratifying and disappointing in the same
way that drugs are you know like you
just sort of you get used to a certain
top you could sort tolerate a certain
amount and you want that again you want
that and then you got to have more and
more and it's the same sort of addictive
properties that drive you towards more
success I think yeah what is uh what
the is a stupid question but I always
say to myself what's the five-year plan
um I will ideally I mean ideal it
doesn't have to be five years but like
what would be like what would be like
your your your best-case scenario well I
would really like to bring another asian
american family to television you know
that's my goal and a different kind of
family that we've ever see why will yeah
that this is something that i tried
before they didn't work and then now
we're living in a new era and this is
something that I I feel oh this is the
time to do it and so now I just I just
been all over you all I get here is you
going like I I could hear you saying
like I I think I'm ready now like and
then repeating all the things that they
didn't like about you like I've lost
weight my face is like I don't want
asian well I know it's different now no
I mean it's um yeah it's definitely all
of these things but not not necessarily
like physically but I'm like now mo old
enough to appreciate it now I'm old
enough to sort of know what to do and to
be more in command of something like
that well yeah I think when you how old
were you and you did that sitcom 22 23
holy hey yeah Cipriano 22 and I imagine
you were just putty and they were just I
was just doing whatever anybody told me
to do cuz I was so scared you know and
now i'm really not afraid which is good
but i was really terrified i'll be a
closure with Gail Berman no I want it
because I I really do love her and it's
unfortunate because the way that I sort
of approached it and talking about it
unfortunately makes it hard for her cuz
it's like she was in the process of you
know doing this she was there and had to
sort of talk to me about certain things
but it wasn't her fault she was just the
messenger she was you know it I they uh
yeah i did a sitcom and the concept of
asian came up with someone and someone
said something really off color and I
was caught off guard when I was like hey
just give me a heads up i wouldn't say
that this person because that person
would be a really upset by they're like
no it's not like i think i'm just
telling you what the truth is mm-hmm and
I was like oh that's even worse oh but
like yeah I think I know that I'd talk
to Titus
about Gil Berman oh I love tide i loved
i really love Titus I really love ty
he's a great guy he's such a good guy he
is a brilliant guy yeah no way he writes
is pretty fascinating he talked to me
about story didn't I tell more stories
on stage I'm not all right very many
jokes and he really kind of broke down
the way he works a story and I kind of
have been applying that that exercise to
my writing now and it helped immensely
yeah that's wonderful um what would be
the what would be the what would be the
like would you would you love would it
be would it would it feel great to wake
up one morning I have an email from Gail
Berman and going hey I'll just saw your
your new Amazon show yeah i mean i would
i would love to talk to her i would love
to have closure with her which I don't
understand why do I don't but I she was
my really good friend and she did take a
big chance on me as a kid and I'll never
forget that I think she's a really great
great great producer and a really good
person and I'd like to see her kids
because now they're all they're all
grown up now yeah the twins are now like
adults um well I I really appreciate you
doing this Margaret I'm yeah I'm I've
been uh I'm a fan of comedy in general
but anyway I've been a fan of yours for
a very long time and to kind of get to
hang out with you and and the coolest
part for me is to get an insight into
your life because you know you're you're
folklore mm with comics you're like
you're not you you're not someone
hanging out at the clubs and drinking
late night and telling all your secrets
too you're someone who shares your
secrets on a global platform or as a
comic would look at it you're like oh
well now my my spray is being allowed to
go a little wider because someone like
Margaret took the chance to to take big
swings now because you do that I get to
do that and so on I mean that your your
ground breaker
you
this episode was brought to you by the
Machine
you